all right everybody knows about this
already but here's the punch line does
this start the Clones Wars
and what I mean by that is what happened
here was that meta proves that you can
take the Instagram community and Port it
over into a new platform this is
different than copying a feature like a
story or a real element and what this
really does is ask the question well why
wouldn't Twitter be working right now on
a direct competitor to reels and to tick
tock and allow you when you sign up to
Port over all your Twitter users and the
same could go for SNAP wise and snap
coming out with a Twitter competitor
there's no reason to not take some
market share maybe you won't be threads
or Twitter but you can be in third place
with nine percent of the market and
that's a big ass business the four to
five leaders Tick Tock YouTube I mean
YouTube should have a Twitter competitor
now and you take all your subscribers
over this move opens up the potential
for massive Clone Wars